i didn't realize you were so friendly
with conan i love conan yeah like you
dropped by his house you must love conan
i i in my book i said he was a favorite
interview of all time i love the guy he
is such a funny bastard he's funny if we
live right near each other i see him see
him and his his son and my daughter went
to
first of all together you downplay every
story you are you are a maniac
first of all adam sandler lives near
conan o'brien so what he does is yeah he
drives by conan's house
like multiple times and your daughters
are in the car and they think this is a
this is a scream yes yeah and you yell
out conan
o'brien that's right right yes
no i i go go then i stay outside this
house is going and it's i've never no
one's replied yet but i do it every time
i ride on my bike bye i slow down i stay
scream going but you do more than that
you do more than that first of all don't
you like then start ringing his bell yes
yes yes and then you then he's not
prepared for you to come off oh yeah
when i do come over right and then you
walk over and you go in there with your
kids and you stay for five minutes and
go kids were not wanted here
that's the story i heard that's that's
right it's kind of dangerous being
friends with you isn't it but you guys
you were friendly from saturday night
live he was great to me when i was on uh
snl he was already there
and i came and hit him robert smeigle
and bob odenkirk they were writers they
wrote and wrote and hung out together
all the time and they
and i knew they were great and and you
said you learned how to write sketches
by reading conan's work right like it
really helped you well his writing was
incredible the other thing though you
did to conan that i love yeah your kids
went to the same school yes so you go to
a parent teacher at night or whatever
and they ask for volunteers and you yell
out ask conan oh yeah i did that dakota
that's so [ __ ] me yeah yeah it was me
and did conan have to he laughed and had
fun he's got the beautiful laugh people
love him